dah  [Music]  the ground but a doctor died  I'm gonna drink the red  from pretty pig face  sorry I don't treat you like a goddess  ouch you want me to do sorry I don't  treat you like you're perfect like all  your little loyal subjects - sorry I'm  not made of sugar my not sweet enough  for you it's that why you always avoid  me that must be such an inconvenience to  do well I'm just your problem  [Music]  I'm just your friend  it's like I'm not even a person  [Music]  I'm just your crowd  well I shouldn't have to justify what I  do  I shouldn't have to prove anything to  you  sorry thou and I exist I forget what  landed me on your black list but I  shouldn't have to be the one who makes  up with you so I - why won't you  [Music]  why do I want to bury you in the ground  and drink the blood from Europe Oh  [Music]